vous attends tu as trouvé un locataire
pour ton studio des locataires gens
trouvent mais avec une caution sûr et
solide c'est une autre histoire
moi j'ai la solution prend et locataires
garantie vise à la garantie d'action
logement en cas d'impayé de loyer c'est
gratuit facile tout se fait en ligne sur
visual point fr visa lepoint fr je me
connecte tout de suite dispositif soumis
à conditions consulter visa lepoint fr
action logement reconnues d'utilité
sociale vous écoutez la première et les
18 heures le journal présenté préparé
par florent marot bonsoir bonsoir redit
bonsoir à tous
deux ans de prison ferme le jeune majeur
qui a blessé un gramoune la semaine
dernière à saint denis a été condamné
ils voulaient lui voler sa carte
bancaire son complice écope de 6 mois
ferme
la précision à suivre des parents devant
la préfecture ce matin pour dénoncer la
loi schiappa une vingtaine de
manifestants se sont mobilisés
pourquoi il y a pourtant eu des mises au
point réaction à suivre la politique et
les municipales de 2020 et dans sa
question après ce journal gay le dantec
reçoit jouer bédié est lundi politique
c'est à 18h15 la fécondation in vitro à
40 ans même si à la réunion la première
fois date de 1986 aujourd'hui 1200
femmes ont recours à la fiv chaque année
et heureusement les techniques ont
évolué nous l'entendrons et puis 350 km
à pied avec un violoncelle sur le dos
n'est pas à la portée du premier venu
c'est pourtant ce que va faire eric
longsworth 59 ans il est à la réunion à
la recherche de rencontres
extraordinaires
l'un part en prison pour deux ans
l'autre écope d'une peine de six mois
ferme mais elles devraient être aménagés
les deux majeurs 18 et 19 ans ont
participé à l'agression d'un gramoune à
saint denis la semaine dernière près de
la cathédrale ils ont donc été jugés et
condamnés ce midi la victime touchée à
la gorge est elle toujours hospitalisé
mais ses jours ne sont plus en danger
et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que les deux
prévenus ont été présentés au tribunal
correctionnel et non devant la cour
d'assises
antoine garnier quelques centimètres de
plus ou de moins et c'était la cour
d'assises pour ismaël et norman sylla
lame du cutter avait touché la carotide
la victime aurait sans aucun doute
succombé avant l'arrivée des secours
cet homme de 76 ans souffre
d'insuffisance rénale donc même une
agression à main nue aurait pu s'avérer
fatale le simple fait de commettre un
vol sous la menace d'une arme et de
nature criminelle
un crime passible de 20 ans de réclusion
rappelle la procureure car c'est bien
pour sa carte bleue et son téléphone
portable que le gramoune a été pris pour
cible il s'était assoupi sur un banc
près de la cathédrale de saint denis
quand vers 2h25 du matin
ce trio composé de deux majeurs et un
mineur a fondu sur lui lui l'homme de 76
ans qui ne peut se déplacer sans sa
paire de béquilles n'a rien pu faire
d'autre que de se débattre
vous êtes parti sans alerter les secours
alors qu'il était en sang accusent
l'avocate du gramoune je n'avais pas vu
qu'il saignait répond ismaël l'auteur du
coup de cutter sans grande conviction
c'est lui qui écope de la plus lourde
peine quatre ans d'emprisonnement dont
deux ferme
les précisions d'antoine garnier le
mineur présent au moment de l'agression
est lui aussi connu de la justice il
sera jugé prochainement devant le
tribunal pour enfants lui y sera jugé
demain matin en comparution immédiate
l'automobiliste à l'origine d'une course
poursuite samedi soir aux camélias
roulait sans permis le s'attendent rien
de 40 ans a refusé de s'arrêter le
chauffard est donc poursuivi pour refus
d'obtempérer défaut de permis et
violences avec arme sur personne
dépositaire de l'autorité publique
les parents de l'école maternelle des
gaspards à sainte marie ont obtenu gain
de cause ils ont bloqué l'établissement
ce matin pour faire part de leurs
inquiétudes quant à la sécurité des
enfants
il n'y aurait plus de secrétaire plus
d'atsem en grande section finalement les
parents ont obtenu une atsem
supplémentaires il y aura donc deux tati
demain pour surveiller les enfants des
parents également devant la préfecture
ce matin pour dénoncer certaines mesures
de la loi schiappa une vingtaine de
manifestants se sont mobilisés malgré
les nombreux démentis
ils réclament un âge minimum claires
pour tout consentement un acte sexuel et
se disent contre les trois séances par
an d'éducation à la vie sexuelle et
affective une mesure loin de faire
l'unanimité
pour les parents les enfants sont trop
petit pour qu'on leur parle de sexualité
d'ailleurs pour eux ce n'est pas le rôle
de l'école je suis pas d'accord que les
enfants connaissent la sexualité et dès
l'âge de 4 ans qu'ils en parlent pour
moi c'est grave c'est pas normal
moi je suis pas d'accord du tout je suis
plutôt bas de décembre mais pas pour les
petits parce que c'est comme si on brise
leur innocence
c'est inadmissible et il ya certains
éléments qui ne sont absolument pas
approprié à la naissance et je pense que
beaucoup de parents pensent comme ça
aussi c'est la raison pour laquelle on
tient à manifester pour dire que ben on
n'est pas d'accord on n'est pas d'accord
par rapport aux standards de l'om s
ensuite est-ce que le gouvernement va ou
pas appliquées le sondage oms est une
autre question est ce que les
professeurs individuellement vont
décider d'appliquer ou pas c'est une
intrication pour ma part j'ai déjà fait
la démarche de rencontrer le professeur
mes enfants et je suis rassuré sur ce
point ils ne vont pas appliquer les
points qui me dérange
maintenant je manifeste quand même pour
dire que ben on est vigilant des
réactions recueillies par johanna
d'amadora six autres mobilisation ce
matin à celles des opposants à la route
des géraniums ils sont allés devant la
pyramide inversée le collectif affirme
que l'annoncent de didier robert la
semaine dernière ne l'a pas tout à fait
rassuré le président de région avait
pourtant dit qu'il abandonnait le projet
malgré tout le collectif a tenu à
remettre à didier robert les 1600
signatures récoltées dans une pétition
les affiches et les voitures sono de
retour
en l'ouest et le sud la campagne
électorale a démarré ce matin à saint
leu les avirons l'étang salé mais aussi
à saint paul saint louis et trois
bassins au total 110 mille électeurs
vont devoir choisir un remplaçant à
thierry robert déchu de son poste de
député dans la 7e circonscription
treize candidats se sont engagés dans
cette législative partielle
lui n'est pas candidat dans la septième
mais il prépare les municipales de 2020
à saint-andré jouer bédier le président
de l'udf
ça sera l'invité de lundi politique ce
soir rendez vous juste après ce journal
avec gaël le dantec
en attendant session plénière reportée
aujourd'hui à la chambre d'agriculture
prévue cet après midi la réunion devait
porter sur la situation budgétaire de la
structure ou encore sur la phase
d'élaboration des listes électorales des
membres de la chambre élections prévues
en janvier 2019 mais aucun de ces points
n'a finalement pu être abordés faute de
quorum
une situation récurrente à la chambre
d'agriculture
les explications de jean bernard
gonthier le président de la chambre
verte depuis la division qui a eu au
sein des études la chambre il y a ceux
qui ne viennent pas propre à venir et il
ya ceux qui se disent on va pas venir
s'il ya un risque de pas voir quorum
parce que il ya le risque qu'ils perdent
leur après midi ce qui est très dommage
c'est que à chaque fois ces dernières
sessions on a dû faire deux sessions
donc c'est du temps perdu par les
budgets eux c'était surtout pour
redemander à la session l'ouverture de
crédits le monde à l'école n'a jamais
était aussi mal que cette année et c'est
pareil pour la chambre
huit cent mille euros de déficit dans
les paiements on a eu du retard on a eu
du retard dans le lancement même du
feader antique le 15 qui vient de sortir
seulement en juillet donc on a dû nous
sur 17 tp payée tune fonds propres ces
lauréats travailler aujourd'hui notre
déficit est due justement à tous est
autant un jean bernard gonthier
président de la chambre d'agriculture
interrogé par mélody nourrit la
prochaine session plénière aura lieu
lundi à 10 septembre et elle se tiendra
même sans quorum
la première 18h07 1978 dans l'hexagone
1986 à la réunion la fiv la fécondation
in vitro à 40 ans et oui elle a été
développée au royaume uni par
le médecin anglais et aujourd'hui chaque
année 1200 femmes ont recours à une fiv
un tiers seulement aboutissent à une
naissance le premier bébé éprouvette
vous l'avez dit est née le 25 juillet
1978 c'était louise brown
il ya 40 ans les femmes représentaient
90 % des cas de stérilité aujourd'hui ce
sont les hommes à 75%
heureusement depuis 1978 la fécondation
in vitro a beaucoup évolué les
précisions de florence caillon
biologiste au centre de procréation du
port une grande nouveauté depuis 40 ans
mais surtout depuis 2012 c'est qu'on
sait congeler les yeux c'est à dire les
vitrifiés et donc on les conserve ce
qu'on ne savait pas faire avancées
congeler du sperme ne savais pas qu'on
gde
donc ça c'est un intérêt dans les
préservation de fertilité quand les
patients sont malheureusement des
maladies qui abîment les spermatozoïdes
et ovules donc on les congèle avant dans
tout ce qui est le traitement cancéreux
donc on les congèle avant qu'il y ait un
problème d'insuffisance ovarienne ou
d'insuffisance spermatique pour les dons
d'ovocytes des patients qui sont
ménopausées à 30 ans on a d e de
donneuses qu'on peut congeler vitrifiés
des jeunes femmes dont 32 ou 33 ans qui
n'ont pas de désir d'enfant on pourrait
éventuellement les stimuler pour
conserver ses yeux pour elle si dans
trois quatre ans et veulent un enfant
florence caillon du port interrogé par
hubert de boeuf lance gaillon biologiste
au centre de procréation du port est
aujourd'hui dans le monde plus de 4
millions d'enfants seraient nés à la
suite d'une fiv santé toujours comment
éviter des scandales sanitaires comme le
levothyrox où le médiator un rapport a
été remis à la ministre de la santé cet
après midi ils pointent des défaillances
dans le système d'information autour des
médicaments c'est pour cela que le
rapport préconise la création d'une
plate-forme médicaments info service
avec un site internet grand public et
une ligne téléphonique pour les
professionnels de santé à des outils
pour que l'information soit plus
accessible plus clair pour claude
rambaud la vice présidente de
l'association de patients le lien elle
ces propositions vont dans le bon sens
mais encore faudrait-il utiliser
efficacement les outils existants
2011après l'acquis du médiator si vous
vous souvenez certainement
il y avait déjà eu la demande d'un
portail
formation il avait déjà été prévu de
mettre en place un portail ciblé
médicaments bon vadam d'usa propose de
renforcer le site sante.fr oui mais pas
vos paires ont véritablement encore donc
c'est vraiment ce site sante.fr d'abord
doit être connue il n'est pas connu des
patients il n'est pas connu du grand
public
je ne sais même pas s'il est connu des
professionnels généralités qui fait des
profits elle qui prescrivent tous les
jours des médicaments donc il doit être
connue il doit être utilisé peut être
terriblement renforcer et là franchement
je compte vraiment sur madame buzyn je
crois que les chasseurs et qu'elle va le
faire claude rambaud vice présidente de
l'association de patients le lien
interrogé par nos confrères de france
info
dans l'hexagone c'était la rentrée des
classes aujourd'hui l'impôt à la source
lui sera-t-il maintenu reporter ou
abandonnés on saura demain tout comme un
éventuel remaniement
on sait déjà que le remplaçant de
nicolas hulot ne sera pas daniel cohn
bendit
[Applaudissements]
en football 16e journée de régionale 1
ce week-end mauvaise opération pour
l'excelsior qui a perdu 2 0 face à
sainte marie surtout que la jeanne d'arc
et la saint-pierroise ont gagné tout
comme le saint denis fc et l'as st
louisienne à victoire aussi de marseille
hier soir 3 buts à 2 face à monaco pour
le compte de la 4e journée de ligue 1
c'est aussi du sport 350 km à pied avec
un violoncelle sur le dos eric
longsworth va le faire cet américain de
59 ans est à la réunion à la recherche
je vous le disais de rencontres
extraordinaires il veut aussi défendre
des valeurs comme la solidarité et le
vivre ensemble
à 48 heures du départ eric longsworth se
souvient de sa première expérience
identique
il y a deux ans entre les alpes et la
suisse il avait alors pu rencontrer des
migrants j'ai envie de partir avec un
ouverture d'esprit et surtout que tout
le monde est bienvenu de marcher
ensemble et de faire la musique ensemble
et de parler ensemble
je trouve que avec les exils de des
exilés par exemple des réfugiés je sais
que c'est c'est des questions qui sont
compliquées il n'y a pas des solutions
toujours facile mais pour moi
l'essentiel c'est l'accueil de l'autre
et ça on peut pas je pars voir autrement
c'est quoi le message lutter contre les
préjugés et les idées préconçues tendre
la main d'être ensemble et je trouve que
par la musique
ça nous donne à une une façon qui va au
delà des frontières de langues
et des barrières culturelles habituel et
aussi par la marche parce que je trouve
que le monteur de la marche
ça permet des vraies rencontres que
notre société hyper rapide nous permet
pas d'habitude
eric longsworth interrogé par philippe
dornier départ mercredi à 9h de la
grotte des premiers français à
saint-paul programme complet sur notre
site internet
c'est la fin de ce journal dans un
instant lundi politique gaël le dantec
reçoit ce soir jouer bédié bonne soirée
sur la première l'info revient à 19h en
télé dès 5h demain matin en radio
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la première
[Musique]
ma fondation est fait
après
[Musique]
l'un d'eux
et
noël
nous
[Musique]
bobby
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
au lait
[Musique]
c
ma
m
ce cas
[Musique]
certes
il est 18h15 vous écoutez la première et
vous avez bien raison rester avec nous
surtout si vous aimez la politique lundi
politique
gaël dantec c'est encore loin 2020 au
portant tous ceux qui espèrent devenir
maire d'une commune lors des prochaines
élections municipales pour eux la
bataille est déjà engagée gestion des
écoles aménagement urbain transport
activités économiques sécurité loisirs
politique sociale ou logement les sujets
ne manquent pas pour ceux qui veulent
proposer des alternatives au pouvoir en
place les challenger s'y prennent tôt
pour trouver une place sur un terrain
médiatique souvent occupés par les
pouvoirs en place
notre invité fait partie de ceux qui se
verraient bien présider un conseil
municipal dans deux ans déjà à premier
adjoint dans le passé ancien du pcr il a
fondé son propre mouvement lui des as à
l'union démocratique pour saint-andré et
a lancé des opérations de communication
pour les prochaines élections
municipales jouer bédié est l'invité de
lundi politique sur la première jusqu'à
19 heures une émission que vous peut
suivre également en vidéo sur notre site
internet
je vais dit bonsoir bonsoir monsieur le
dantec ben on s'attendrait bonsoir la
réunion merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans l'actualité politique il
ya la campagne qui débute dans la 7e
circonscription pour l'élection
législative partielle et vous
comprendrez que pour respecter le temps
de parole de chacun des candidats nous
ne parlerons pas ici de cette campagne
nous aurons l'occasion sur la première
de donner la parole aux candidats et à
leurs soutiens dans l'actualité
politique il est aussi la démission de
nicolas hulot
l'ancien alors vous allez me dire qu'on
est loin de saint-andré mais j'aimerais
quand même avoir votre avis sur sur cet
événement l'ancien ministre d'état en
charge de la transition énergétique a
jeté l'épongé ne souhaitant pas que sa
présence au gouvernement laisse penser
que nous serions à la hauteur des enjeux
concernant l'avenir de la planète
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire vous en
tant qu'homme politique en tant qu'élu 7
cette décision moi j'ai envie de vous
dire que cette démission était couru
d'avancé
dès que des dit que j'ai appris moi même
le nicolas hulot devenait ministre de
ministre je savais qu'il n'allait pas
non plus faire long feu à ce poste
puisque souvenez-vous de ce qu'avait dit
nicolas sarkozy
un ministre ça ferme sa gueule ou ça
démissionne et connaissant nicolas hulot
et sans combat pour la protection de
l'environnement
on savait que ça allait être difficile
et voilà donc on voit le résultat
aujourd'hui on a le sentiment d'entendre
nicolas hulot que la vision à court
terme du mandat politique
la proximité toujours des futures
échéances empêche finalement toute
politique environnementale sur du long
terme et plus globalement que l'action
politique
finalement est entravée par les lobbys
économiques par des décisions
donc soit électoraliste du côté
politique soit influencée par des lobbys
économiques
c'est totalement vrai c'est totalement
vrai malgré tout vous croyez encore la
politique j'y crois il faut il faut il
faut y croire et j'encourage aussi tout
le monde à ne pas à ne pas baisser les
bras parce que on dit souvent que si on
ne s'occupe pas de la politique est bien
la politique
il s'occupe de vous et donc à partir de
là non non ce n'est pas que dans le
secteur de l'environnement
effectivement on est tout le temps dans
les calculs électoraux à peine en place
les élus pensent tout de suite aux
prochaines échéances
et c'est ça qui fait qu'on n'avance pas
qu'on ne se penche pas sur les dossiers
et moi même j'ai trop vu ça et je tout
le temps je répète que si demain
j'occupe une vraie une haute
responsabilité notamment
celle de maire ne comptez pas sur moi
dès mon installation dans le fauteuil de
maire pour rassembler mon équipe pour
leur dire ben voilà comment il faut
faire pour être élu au prochain mandat
non il faut tout de suite se mettre au
travail et travailler sur les dossier
qui est important
ça veut dire aussi prendre le risque
éventuellement de pâtes réélu c'est pas
grave c'est pas grave l'essentiel c'est
de travailler pour la réunion de travail
et pour sa ville et pour la population
parce que sinon ça reste des intérêts
personnels
je me dis vous êtes donc candidat on l'a
compris à la mairie de saint-andré en
2020 2020 c'est normalement la date pour
les prochaines municipales mais ça peut
encore bouger sur voila il peut y avoir
quelques quelques semaines quelques mois
de mobilité dans cette date vous avez
déjà commencé votre campagne
depuis quelques mois déjà vous êtes
déclaré est ce que c'est un peu tôt
quand même pour partir je n'ai pas peur
de lasser de vous lasser de lasser les
éventuels électeurs mais non quand vous
dites que je suis en campagne
en réalité je ne fais que mon travail
d'opposant et ce depuis 2014
je n'ai rien lâché contrairement à
d'autres ce que j'appelle mollet les
ouvriers de la 25e heure qu'on reverra
de trois mois avant les élections
lorsqu'on m'a donné un mandat et un
mandat même si je suis dans l'opposition
c'était pour assumer cette
responsabilité là et ce n'est pas trop
tôt que de travailler d'assumer ses
responsabilités politiques et non non
moi je ne pense pas placé au contraire
informé continuer à travailler at proche
de la population
c'est un travail comme un autre d'être
un élu de l'opposition
si demain je suis dans la majorité ben
je pourrais la travailler directement
sur les dossiers mais je le fais
vraiment avec plaisir et c'est comme ça
qu'il faut que tout le monde doit faire
est ce que est ce que justement est-ce
qu'être dans l'opposition
aujourd'hui compte tenu de la façon dont
la politique se fait dans une mairie à
la réunion dans une municipalité est ce
que être dans l'opposition aujourd'hui
c'est assez faire de l'opposition au
conseil municipal
est-ce que c'est essayer de survivre
médiatiquement jusqu'à la prochaine
élection
ou est ce qu'on peut faire un peu de de
co-construction finalement avec avec la
même majorité en place est ce que on
peut travailler sur des dossiers
travailler sur des dossiers non puisque
c'est le groupe majoritaire qui
travaille sur les dossiers
l'élu de l'opposition que je suis est là
pour suivre les dossiers et quand c'est
bon on vote puisqu'il faut pas croire
quand je vais en conseil municipal je
vote systématiquement contre quand c'est
bon on vote
et quand c'est pas bon on dit pourquoi
c'est pas bon pour essayer de faire
comprendre l'autre que ben il ya des
choses peut être à revoir à modifier ou
à faire on va on va parler des sujets
évidemment de la politique locale et
notamment de saint-andré mais ça se
passe à saint-andré mais parfois les
dossiers les électeurs des autres
communes s'y retrouveront mais d'abord
sur la forme sur la campagne que vous
commencez malgré tout à mener quels sont
les moyens vous mettez en oeuvre on a
l'impression que vous vous mettez un peu
le paquet on voit des vidéos vous avez
de janval écrit vous êtes vous avez vous
lu quand même dès le départ mettre des
moyens on travaille sur des outils de
communication etc nécessaires depuis
depuis 2014 même avant 2014
bon après on s'améliore aujourd'hui on
en parle mais ces outils existent
mon journal papier 440 vérité il existe
depuis 2013 après on a fait une web tv
et maintenant on a la version en 440
vérité papier en version numérique
ça fait partie de notre temps et on ne
peut pas faire l'impasse aujourd'hui sur
ces moyennes communication parce que
c'est comme ça ça coûte cher ça coûte un
peu d'argent
ça coûte un peu d'argent mais ça coûte
aussi ça coûte aussi du temps du temps
le temps c'est de l'argent et du temps
et de l'argent que vous trouvez où ben
disons que concernant
petit les petits moyens de communication
que nous avons aujourd'hui c'est de ma
poche
et puis à un peu de lui des essarts mon
mouvement politique lorsqu'on organise
des petites manifestations on arrive
toujours grappiller quelques petits
quelques euros je vais dire mais en même
temps ce qu'on réalise ne coûte pas non
plus des milliers et des milliers
aujourd'hui on peut faire de la
communication sans avoir dé justement
engager des frais importants parce que
alors on le sait les frais de campagne
c'est un vrai sujet parce que après
chaque élection il ya des recours oui
vous avez dépensé temps vous avez fait
ceci c'est tout c'est 13 13 ans très
encadrée aujourd'hui vous dites on peut
faire de la communication politique
relativement moderne avec de la vidéo
avec des choses dans les rets sur les
réseaux sociaux sans dépenser des
fortunes
c'est vrai c'est vrai le le plus le plus
difficile aujourd'hui c'est de trouver
les ressources les personnes ressources
pour mettre en place puisque moi j'aime
pas non plus faire des choses à moitié
je dis pas que c'est totalement bien ce
qu'on fait mais en même temps en temps
vers que vers vers le quelque chose de
bien de moderne de et non pas faire pour
faire quoi
vous avez été premier adjoint à la
mairie de saint-andré alors qu'il faut
tout était maire c'était entre 2008 et
2014 et y ait ensuite candidats
en 2014 avait d'élus en 2015 conseiller
régional sur la liste avec une haie de
bello et gilbert annette quel est votre
positionnement politique aujourd'hui pcr
plr ps vous avez travail avec tous ces
gens là aujourd'hui en atout alors mes
relations sont sont bonnes bien
évidemment avec l'ensemble des personnes
qui des composantes du groupe le
rassemblement de conduite par huguette
bello de bonnes relations de travail
récemment encore on a été tous à
saint-paul soutenir le candidat alors
nous envisager de parler sur vos
relations avec le pcr vous en est où
pour être franc je n'ai plus de relation
avec le pcr depuis les dernières
municipales
je vais pas ici pratiquer la langue de
bois et souvenez-vous lorsque j'étais
candidat en sélection donc départemental
de 2015 j'avais dit au premier tour
de toute façon quoi qu'il arrive il y
aura le désistement républicain
si je suis derrière je soutiendrai le
candidat progressiste mais se trouve
aussi que mes camarades du pcr non
seulement ils m'ont ils n'ont pas
soutenu mais on fait une déclaration
dans la presse disant que banon nous on
peut pas suivre bédié c'est à
l'arrogance et c'est enfin bref quoi on
m'a trouvé toutes sortes de défaut pour
ne pas me soutenir mais moi je dis
demain dans une élection quelle qu'elle
soit si je suis derrière
et bien le candidat progressiste peut
qu'on pourra compter sur mon soutien
et c'est ainsi que je me conduis en
politique je reste dans ma ligne et je
ne trouve pas des excuses ou des motifs
invraisemblable pour fuir
pour fuir mes responsabilités quel
regard vous portez aujourd'hui sur sur
justement sur le pcr et sur votre
passage au pcr sur mon passage au pca je
peux je peux vous dire que je ne
regrette rien absolument rien regretter
pas d'y être allé et de l'avoir quittée
de l'avoir quittée non plus mais je ne
regrette pas d'être passé au pcr et
d'avoir côtoyé des personnes qui m'ont
beaucoup appris
c'était une très bonne école pour moi
mais il se trouve aussi après bah voilà
ainsi va la vie et chacun voit à sa
façon avec ses avec ses valeurs et donc
jeunes moment donné on je ne partageais
plus je ne partageais plus il faut
parler franc certains fonctionnements et
du coup je me suis dit dorénavant moi je
ne veux plus non plus être être toujours
derrière
pourquoi pas puisque moi je suis très
focalisé sur sa tendresse et ma ville
créé son propre mouvement et y aller et
c'est comme ça que je conçois
aujourd'hui la politique ne plus non
plus être dépendant être dépendant de
gros partis politiques c'est très
difficile puisqu'il faut être toujours à
l'écouté et et moi j'aime pas trop
quelquefois sortir de ma ligne de
conduite et de mes valeurs et c'est pour
ça qu'aujourd'hui je me sens bien dans
mon mouvement politique et vous vous
diriez toujours communiste
aujourd'hui je non je dirais pas ça
puisque j'ai mon propre mouvement
mouvement ouvert avec toutes les toutes
les bonnes volontés possible mais je me
situe comme un homme de gauche
vous avez on l'a dit a ouvert un peu le
bal de cette campagne pour les
municipales à saint-andré vous avez
notamment critiqué récemment la façon
dont se déroule la rentrée dans
certaines écoles
on va rentrer dans le vif des sujets de
politique locale
ça se passe à saint-andré mais ça se
passe
aussi ailleurs pourtant ils sont pas y
avoir de gros problèmes pour cette
rentrée à saint-andré en tout cas c'est
par remonter de manière non mais oui
vous avez raison de le dire il n'y a pas
eu véritablement de problème grave
j'ai quand même signalé lors de ma
conférence de presse quelques quand même
quelques problèmes qui me touche
personnellement parce que je suis
j'écoute beaucoup les personnes
et lorsqu'il s'agit notamment des
personnes qui sont les plus vulnérables
les plus faibles il ya eu des
déplacements vous savez c'est quand même
des drames humains des personnes qui
travaillent depuis quarante ans quand
déplacent de manière un peu autoritaire
en biterre et qui pleure et qui ne
comprennent pas qu'ils ne conduisent pas
qu'on déplace sur des distances
relativement longue
voilà c'est quand même pour moi des
problèmes importants mais bon en même
temps je peux pas dire là qu il y avait
il y a eu des deux gros problèmes
une des grandes difficultés pour les
mairies en cette rentrée comme comme la
rentrée un précédentes c'est la gestion
des atsem dans beaucoup de deux mairies
le personnel qui est donc les
professeurs des écoles dans l'est dans
les écoles dans les cas ce maternelle
souvent c'est du personnel communal
précaire des emplois aidés vous dites
parce que on sait bien que ces emplois
aidés diminue est ce que vous dites il
faut embaucher il faut que ce personnel
soit du personnel titulaire qualifié
pour remplir ces fonctions là où est ce
qu'il faut faire avec des emplois dès
qu'on a de moins en moins comment est ce
qu'on s'en sort aujourd'hui je pense que
vous avez là vraiment se poser à un vrai
problème concernant le personnel des
écoles at celles effectivement moi je ça
c'est ma conception des choses
concernant le personnel des écoles c'est
un choix c'est un choix politique
pas grand monde ne l'a fait jusqu'ici
en tous les cas à ma connaissance pas ce
qu'il faut demain c'est avoir un certain
à personnel non pas précaire mais
impersonnel ou véritablement et une
formation déjà à la base
vous vous rendez pas compte mara on m'a
remonté à un moment que sur la même la
même année scolaire
il ya des personnes dont le contrat se
termine et l'enfant se retrouve avec une
personne différente en cours d'année
alors qu'elle est habituée avec l'autre
et c'est pour cette raison qu
effectivement il faut professionnaliser
il faut véritablement que ce personnel
deviennent du personnel n'ont pas
précaire mais du père ça veut dire qu'il
faut embaucher
il faut embaucher vous savez si on parle
de saint-andré aujourd'hui s'attendrait
à un effectif en équivalent temps plein
de 1500 personnes
il faut peut-être revoir l'organisation
et puis et puis mettre les gens à l'oral
à leur place là où il est il trouve là
là là leur comment dirais-je leur
bonheur si on peut dire et puis et puis
et puis mettre en place une politique de
formation professionnelle choses qui
n'existent quasiment pas à saint-andré
mais ça coûte cher
qu est ce qui coûte cher de former les
gens de les embaucher de l'or les
décontracter contrats précaires vous
savez le budget de la formation
professionnelle c'est un pourcentage qui
est pris sur la masse salariale le
budget existe après la formation ça peut
se faire aussi en interne il ya on
trouve toujours les moyens mais il faut
vouloir il faut vouloir aller tendre
vers ça
la baisse des emplois aidés est ce que
ça veut dire que finalement c'est une
bonne mesure annoncée par par le
gouvernement de dire ben il faut pas des
emplois précaires il faut c'est pas des
vrais emplois d'ailleurs le volet
insertion des contrats aidés ne
fonctionne pas n'a pas fonctionné
n'amène pas vers de l'emploi pérenne
donc il faut supprimer ce dispositif
ça fait évidemment grincer beaucoup de
dents à la réunion vous vous positionnez
comme en moi je ne dirais pas que là la
baisse des emplois et des thunes est une
bonne chose non non je ne suis pas le
gouvernement là dessus en tous les cas
ça a été fait relativement trop
rapidement
il voulait véritablement à un moment
donné arrêtez avec les contrats aidés
mais il faut où il faut travailler en
amont sur une politique économique ici à
la réunion de manière à créer des
emplois si on a eu recours jusqu'ici à
des emplois aidés c'était pour compenser
le monde d'emploi vous savez au dernier
dernières publications de paul de pôle
emploi
c'est plus de 140 mille chômeurs et donc
voila moi je pense que supprime on
supprime des emplois aidés mais dans le
même temps on ne met rien en place pour
permettre aux réunionnais de d'accéder à
un emploi
et c'est là la difficulté on aurait pu
on aurait pu on aurait pu à terme
puisque moi je pense pas que ça soit
véritablement ça soit une bonne chose
dans le temps que d'être tout le temps
sur dans la précarité
il ya moyen aujourd'hui ici à la réunion
et ça c'est le rôle de la région entre
de mettre en place un développement
économique
alors on va y venir pour terminer sur
ces emplois précaires ces emplois aidés
ces petits contrats on sait bien que le
maire est dans une position délicate
parce que c'est lui qui reçoit les
familles qui cherchent un travail et que
on se retrouve vite en position
finalement posture un peu un peu
clientéliste parce que parce que les
gens vont voter pour vous parce que vous
avez trouvé un petit contrat parce que
vous avez pu aider telle ou telle
famille comment est-ce qu'on on peut
rompre avec cette cette histoire-là delà
de la politique réunionnaise comment est
ce que est ce que finalement est ce que
vous avez envie vous si vous étiez
demain de nouveau aux manettes ce que
est ce qu'on peut supprimer ça est ce
qu'on peut dire aux journaux
ici c'est pas pour l'emploi vous allez
voir ailleurs non il faut pas dire les
choses il faut pas dire les choses comme
ça mais en même temps il faut il faut
bien il faut comprendre aussi les
personnes aujourd'hui qui sollicitent la
mairie puisque ils sont pour la plupart
tous inscrits à pôle emploi et y'a rien
du tout donc
le maire devient véritablement une
espèce de dernier recours vers qui on
s'adresse et on demande un petit quelque
chose
moi je ne je ne je ne conçois pas non
plus demain d'aller d'aller m'appuyer
sur la misère ou la demande des gens
pour faire une politique ou pour vendre
mon mon projet pas du tout jeune je ne
pourrais pas faire ça puisque j'aimerais
pas être à la place de quelqu'un à qui
on promet qui attend et qui est que rien
ne vient moi je pense que je serai plus
partant à saint-andré pour mettre en
place véritablement un projet de
développement économique et de dire aux
gens la vérité c'est à dire demain en
mairie
il faut être il faut être franc n'aura
pas travail pour tout le monde puisque
déjà je vous ai dit tout à l'heure 1500
personnes en équivalent temps plein dans
l'effectif de saint-andré quand
l'équivalent en métropole même strate
ces 800 personnes vous comprenez que l'
on ne peut plus sur le budget de
fonctionnement puisque ça pénalise
l'investissement
donc voilà il faut il faut travailler
sur le sur le volet économique pour
attirer des investisseurs vous savez moi
je refais justement pour créer de
l'emploi on va revenir sur des projets
peut-être qu'ils sont proposés par le
par le maire actuel aux hippies là
l'occasion à chaque fois qu'il a
l'occasion de d'en parler il les évoque
un grand port de la vente d'eau douce de
deux des formations au numérique des
nouvelles technologies qui pourraient
apporter des emplois aussi sur sur
saint-andré ce sont des projets que vous
que vous soutenez vous vous dites bâle
allant du banco tous ensemble sur ce
genre de projet où vous dites ont
l'intention c'est pas la bonne idée non
non non moi je suis pas du tout dans son
registre lui l'huile est tout le temps
dans les effet d'annonce on le pratique
depuis très longtemps et ceux qui
m'écoutent aujourd'hui à saint-andré
sont habitués depuis l'hôtel float en
passant par l' usine savons enfin bref
il nous a promis plein de choses qu'on
n'a jamais vues qui a jamais vu le jour
non moi je ne suis pas du tout dans son
registre et d'ailleurs vous même vous
venez
de citer encore quelques quelques-uns de
projets type pour du cosmétique est tout
juste s'ils voulaient pas remplacé
madame bettencourt enfin bref quoi moi
ce que je veux c'est mettre en place une
politique de développement économique
réaliste c'est à dire la balle c'est
quoi c'est de mettre en place un outil
qui n'existe pas aujourd'hui c'est à
dire une véritable zone d'activités pour
permettre aux entreprises de s'implanter
je cite toujours l'exemple de sainte
marie on est à quelques pas de la ville
de sainte-marie et qu'est ce que je vois
qu est ce que je constate c'est que là
bas il ya beaucoup d'investisseurs qui
se sont implantés pourquoi parce qu'il
ya vu parce que il ya eu une volonté du
maire d'attirer ces investisseurs ils
sont pas venu comme ça puisque vous
s'attendre et c'est à pois 15 minutes de
gillot et bientôt avec la route la
nouvelle route du littoral 6-6-6 sa voie
le jour on sera allé à une demi heure
voire 35 minutes du port donc on a là
tout le potentiel pour attirer des
investisseurs encore faut-il le vouloir
et avoir la capacité aussi d'accueillir
après les investisseurs y suffit pas de
vouloir il faut mettre les outils en
place l'idée de faire un grand port à
s'entendre c'est pas une bonne idée je
ne dis pas que c'est pas une bonne idée
mais en même temps c'est pareil en vend
en vend du vent depuis depuis x temps
l'eau vous souvenez vous il a fait sa
campagne électorale il a dit il a promis
qu'il allait vendre de l'eau dans les
pays du golfe
quand les saint-andréens boivent de
l'eau sale non mais il faut arrêter moi
je pense qu'il faut on ne peut plus on
n'a pas le droit on n'a plus le droit de
jouer avec les gens est ici à quelque
chose que j'ai bien compris et dont je
suis heureux aujourd'hui c'est que
maintenant la population c'est fini
c'est plus comme avant avant on mettait
30 ans pour comprendre aujourd'hui on
n'est pas bon on vous vire le mandat
suivant tu sais ça c'est une chose
véritablement vous allez voir vous
journalistes vous allez pouvoir le
constater dorénavant la population de la
réunion et notamment celle de
saint-andré
nathan plus 30 ans pour virer quelqu'un
on a fait des promesses qu'on n'a pas
tenu ses promesses
on dégage il ya un sujet sur lequel jean
paul virapoullé s'est exprimé également
ces dernières semaines ces derniers mois
et qui concerne tout le monde sait c'est
la gestion des déchets avec un recours
qui avait opposé la cirest aux tribunaux
administratifs au sydney le syndicat en
charge de déchets pour pour l'est et le
nord il y a un contrat qui avait été
signé donc entre sydney et innovest pour
le traitement le stockage
l'enfouissement la valorisation des
déchets collectés donc sur le nord et
l'est
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui se passe
derrière ce set
cette histoire un peu complexe à suivre
pour nous et pour eux imaginent pour
tous les administrés parce qu'au fond il
ya quand même un problème c'est qu'il ya
des déchets qui s'entassent le centre
d'enfouissement de sainte suzanne est
plein il va bien falloir trouver une
solution et on comprend pas bien où est
ce qu'on va leur vous enfin quand vous
dites qu'on ne comprend pas bien où est
ce qu'on va lui comprend parfaitement
c'est que lui voulait tout attirée sur
la zone de bois rouge chose qui n'a pas
été vu de la même manière par le
président de la cinor donc il ya des
recours il en a perdu je crois deux ou
trois déjà mais son sens son son
objectif à lui c'était de tout mettre
sur la zone de bois rouge c'est pas une
bonne idée c'est pas une bonne idée moi
je dis pas que c'est pas une bonne idée
mais on peut pas non plus s'associer
avec des partenaires et puis vouloir
après déshabiller ce partenaire pour
pour attirer tout sur son territoire il
faut il faut être correct
et puis nous mêmes à s'attendre et moi
j'avais j'avais j'ai entendu jean paul
virapoullé dire un moment que lui demain
même on sait tous que le centre
d'enfouissement de sainte suzanne est
saturé et il a une demande
d'autorisation de carrier assure bras
mousseline en cours il avait même dit
que lorsque ce centre d'enfouissement
sera saturé lui les prêts après
exploitation de la carrière et je crois
que sa salsa dura à peu près 5 6 ans il
est prêt à recueillir le centre
d'enfouissement de sainte-suzanne que
bruce lee nous
des comptes ne peut pas non plus non
plus nous à saint-andré accueillir tous
sur notre territoire parce que monsieur
le maire a des intérêts ou j'en sais
trop rien tout ça se
tout ça c'est des choses qu'il faut
discuter avec les partenaires et voire
même la population vous préconisez quoi
pour la gestion de déchets moi je
préconise que de toute façon j'étais je
les ai toujours dit si les politiques
actuelles qui sont responsabilité ne
s'entendent pas vous savez c'est le
préfet un jour qui décidera mais pour
l'instant moi ce que je pense c'est bien
c'est plutôt bien parti puisque la cinor
à son projet à travers le sydney le
syndicat sydney et donc voilà donc lui
il voulait même mettre un incinérateur
sur bois rouge vous là aussi ça pose
problème
là aussi ça pose problème danse lors de
sa campagne électorale il n'avait pas
parlé d'incinérateurs et du coup dans
son projet qui voulait implanter sur le
sur bois rouge
il y avait cet incinérateur qu'ils
appellent autrement mais c'est un assidu
c'est sa valorisation énergétique
on va écouter un peu de musique avant de
poursuivre cet entretien la musique
c'est vous qui l'avez choisie vous
réveillez vous avez choisi bon dieu de
quesnel on l'écouté on en parle après
[Musique]
tous
narry qu'un seul mais il donne à - la
fosse
ah ben si
[Musique]
peu importe ce qui arrive en moins
lille et la mer
il a pas moins été un ebay tous en main
un panneau baissier
il donne mon vécu
[Musique]
ce
g on l'a toujours dit à moi
pouvoir en ci
pourquoi ben on vit un peu la nique aux
mauvais
et appelle à lille
à peine ali chiba
ali m
vva
sow
on prend à toi
[Musique]
après la liseuse
à peine
[Musique]
oda
dir
[Musique]
mais
le prix
[Musique]
non
avec votre famille
il est
[Musique]
rybak été
oui oui pour elle
m
yves espoir ou avant
mais n'a pas pu être à cassis
non
comme alizée ou deux mais coller
ensemble
et à vous dire
en janvier
la ligue au mans
bon bien choisi par notre invité jouer
bédié conseiller municipal d'opposition
à saint-andré conseiller régional
d'opposition également et président de
son mouvement lui dsk pourquoi cette
chanson jouée bédié pourquoi cette
chanson basse et c'est une chanson que
j'écoute pas mal ces derniers temps elle
m'a plu parce que il y a dans cette
chanson des messages quand on regarde la
photo sur l'album on voit une jeune
femme plutôt frêle mais mais qui envoie
qui fait passer des messages et qui plus
est dans ici à la réunion dans
concernant notre vivre ensemble moi je
trouve ça fort et puis elle à s'entendre
il faut avancer il faut pas il faut pas
s'arrêter sur les sur les coups bas et
il faut positiver moi je
je trouve ça merveilleux puis une
musicalité aussi que j'apprécie on voit
en ce moment dans la france hexagonale
un mouvement de maires de petites
communes qui jette l'épongé parce que
les responsabilités sont trop lourdes
quand on est à la tête d'une mairie
parce que les moyens sont plus en plus
réduits on n'a pas parlé on pourrait
peut-être en dire un mot les les
dotations du gouvernement sont sont
régulièrement en baisse pourquoi est ce
que vous avez envie d'y aller vous c'est
quoi c'est le goût du pouvoir
le goût du pouvoir n'en sait surtout
l'amour pour ma ville et et pour la
population parce que quand on quand on a
ce côté de vouloir faire avancer de
vouloir aider
je dirais pas que c'est le goût du
pouvoir c'est le le vouloir aider le
vouloir accompagner sa ville vers un
développement puisque on ne peut pas
accepter on ne peut pas tolérer de voir
sa ville sans français comme ça année
après année alors qu'on a du potentiel
on a parlé un petit peu environnement
avec les déchets qu'un autre dossier lié
à l'environnement celui des carrières il
ya sur votre territoire à saint-andré
plusieurs projets et notamment pour le
projet car la durée que d'alimenter le
chantier de la nouvelle route du
littoral
et puis il démarre pas qu'est-ce qui se
passe la carrière de dioré il ya eu le
la cour d'appel de bordeaux qui a annulé
le schéma départemental des carrières de
ce fait là
l'autorisation de dioré s'arrêter et
mais à ce propos moi je vous je les dis
sur le sur le schéma des carrières ce
qu'il faut faire et j'aimerais qu'on
nous entende une bonne fois pour toutes
puisque quand j'entends ceux de l'ouest
ou du sud ouest
j'ai comme l'impression qu' il dise bien
la banane à la possibilité fait cai est
allé fait là bas nous moi je lance un
appel aux préfets pour dire qu' il faut
un amas il faut demain faire en sorte
que sur les autorisations des carrières
il faut que ce soit équitable
il faut que ce soit équitable sur
l'ensemble de l'île
lille c'est quatre micro région sud
ouest nord et sud et est
on en fait une carrière dans chaque
microrégion et le problème est réglé
mais souvent j'entends notamment un élu
la banane à dioré la banane à bras panon
mais pourquoi nous les gens de bras
panon de saint benoît de saint-andré et
de cette microrégion ils sont moins que
ceux de
de votre côté là bas on a besoin aussi
nous qu'on tienne compte de la santé que
de la tranquillité de ses habitants et
qu'on les respecte
faisons un schéma départemental des
carrières équitable équilibré en terme
d'aménagement il ya plusieurs dossiers
en ce moment l'aménagement de la ville
et un peu c'est un peu un casse-tête à
ce qu'il faut déclasser des terrains
agricoles pour développer l'urbanisation
l'industrie est ce qu'il faut au
contraire préserver ces terrains pour
des espaces verts pour l'avenir ce qu'il
faut maintenir une agriculture autour de
saint-andré comment est-ce que et puis
après en terme d'aménagement de la ville
même comment est-ce que quels sont les
grands les grands sujets sur la table
bah écoutez sur l'aménagement du
territoire
concernant s'attendrait il faut savoir
que sa tendresse et on va dire le mi
rural mire urbain est effectivement
l'agriculture compte pour une pour une
bonne partie est
mais bon sur l'aménagement du territoire
moi je pense que ça a été fait un peu un
peu gros doigts mais ce n'est pas si
demain on arrive aux responsabilités il
ya encore moyen de véritablement prendre
la chose et d'aller dans le bon sens
mais moi le bon sens le bon sens et ceux
de ne plus autoriser
[Musique]
il faut absolument qu'on arrive à faire
des zones urbaines et non pas faire d
laisser faire des constructions de
manière un peu et passe on va dire
et donc voilà tout ça c'est pour aussi
tenir compte de l'agriculture ya des
zones où il faut préserver pour
l'agriculture il ya des zones où il va
falloir densifier concernant
l'urbanisation et tout ça il faut que ce
soit dans un schéma cohérent et non pas
n'importe comment est-ce que saint-andré
manque de logements s'attendrait
probablement manque de logements comme
partout puisque on connaît tous ici les
demandes de logements qui sont en
souffrance mais en même temps moi je
pense qu'on n'est pas très on n'est pas
aussi en retard sur notamment concernant
la loi sru sur les logements sociaux on
en a pas mal quand même à s'attendre et
après il va falloir que les autres
prennent un peu aussi et voilà il faut
voilà c'est une question d'équilibré
moi je pense que ça tendrait ne peut pas
prendre tout non plus comme les
carrières moi je pense que les logements
sociaux est moment donné sur la micro
région et va falloir aussi qu'on se
concerte pour pour établir un plan
concernant les logements sociaux
la mairie a signé avec la police est
avec l'état un protocole pour associer
les citoyens à la sécurité
il ya un problème vous voudriez un
problème de sécurité à saint-andré
est-ce que éventuellement c'est une
solution d'associer les citoyens à cette
lutte contre l'insécurité
l'association des citoyens
c'est si ça peut aider mais en même
temps ce n'est pas la solution
ce n'est pas la solution moi je pense
qu'on a des fonctionnaires aujourd'hui
est amer qui est en place moi le premier
constat que j'ai pu faire lors de son
arrivée en 2014
c'est le dépôt le démantèlement de la
police municipale il en a mis plein au
placard ils envoyaient dot dans des
quartiers sans voitures
c'est aussi des placards donc voilà il
ya l'absence de prévention
et puis cette absence du maire il faut
il faut il faut le dire le maire est
absent et quand il est là et il est
occupé à lui qui règle les problèmes de
sécurité
ben le maire à rôle un rôle puisque moi
si si si demain je suis à sa place je
mettrai en place régulièrement au moins
au moins une fois tous les trois mois
une réunion avec la police nationale
municipale puisque c'est le maire quand
même qu'ils organisent la sécurité sur
son territoire
il faut qu'ils sachent il faut qu'ils
qui se concertent qu'il discute avec
cette police moi je souhaiterais donc
reconstitué renforcer la police
municipale renforcée la police la
présence policière sur le terrain afin
de rassurer la population des acteurs
économiques mettre en place une vraie
politique de prévention associant tous
les acteurs c'est-à-dire la justice les
divas police l'éducation nationale les
associations de quartier c'est important
et puis bien évidemment les commerçants
et chefs d'entreprise tous à travailler
en concertation
je pense qu'il est nécessaire chose qui
n'existe pas actuellement faut plus de
présence policière plus de de prévention
vous dites d'accompagnement de politique
sociale en faveur des jeunes avant
qu'ils basculent dans la délinquance
c'est quoi votre priorité
bien évidemment c'est ça c'est un point
important il faut déjà travailler sur
les personnes en difficulté il faut
mettre en place mais pourquoi on fait
comment concrètement parce que
concrètement moi la première chose que
si demain je suis mère que je mettrai en
place c'est une service jeunesse un
véritable service jeunesse qui
travaillerait avec tous les réseaux
existant déjà
aujourd'hui personne ne fait un cas avec
la jeunesse et puis le résultat il est
là puisque vous savez que la sécurité à
saint-andré aujourd'hui malheureusement
ma ville aujourd'hui et est abonnée aux
rubrique des faits divers
et il ne se passe pas un jour si des
personnes à s'attendre et ne se fasse
pas cambriolé hier encore à ravine
creuse voiture volée maison cambriolée
bijoux etc
c'est tous les jours et c est ce assez
significatif si on ne réagit pas là on
fait quoi
les gens payent des impôts pour qu'il
vivre dans la tranquillité pour qu'ils
soient protégés et ce n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui
je vous disais j'allais vous dire tout à
l'heure lorsque le maire est là à 80% il
est occupé pour la succession c'est à
dire la placer son fils à la mairie et
ça vous énerve ça ça cesse ça m'énerve
ça m'énerve parce que vous savez je me
suis housse aussi fâché avec l'autre
entre autres à cause de ça je ne
comprends vite l'autre ceux qui parce
que là il faut faute clairs pour nos
auditeurs le prédécesseur le voulait
molaires son nom la boue non ce n'est
pas tabou mais en même temps je vous dis
pas de qui vous parlez
l'ex maire jean paul virapoullé qui dont
on parle est habituellement qui est
maire qui intronise son fils pour lui
succéder ça vous énerve et vous dit à
quelqu'un d'autre voulait pas dire son
nom
baboo bien bien évidemment c'est
inacceptable cette vous avez vu le luxe
et c'est jean paul virapoullé lui même
qui sur la place de la mairie annonce
que ce sera son son son fils qui prendra
le relais en démocratie et dans tout
mouvement qui se respecte ça se passe
pas comme ça on s'attendrait regarder le
titre de mon journal ça s'attendrait
n'est pas une royauté
ça sera un bon adversaire pour vous jean
marie virapoullé
ça sera un candidat comme comme un autre
moi je ne regarde pas les autres
moi je suis là pour demain ce que c'est
ce que je fais déjà pour aller à la
rencontre de la population pour leur
dire que ma allons-y il est temps de
tourner la page puisque saint-andré a
besoin de nous de nous tous et parce que
ça tendrait a du potentiel
nous l'aimons et nous voulons qu'elle
avance il reste quelques quelques
secondes avant de terminer cette
émission une question qu'on pose de à
peu près tout le temps passe et les
personnalités politiques qui viennent à
ceux à ce micro comment est ce que vous
gagnez votre vie vous vous gagnez
combien alors moi je travaillais la
caisse d'allocations familiales
je suis alors je j'ai encore quelques
petites minutes
non pas que pendant quelques secondes ne
pourra pas abordé le
la politique nationale non mais notre
foi une autre fois ok comment je gagne
moi je travaillais la caisse
d'allocations familiales enquêteurs je
suis tous les jours sur le terrain je
vais rencontrer les gens pour les aider
concernant l'amélioration de logements
donc vous n'avez pas des revenus autres
qui vous permettent de financer votre
campagne de chaque campagne vous savez
comment je fais je vais à la banque je
fais un prêt l'avantagent que j'ai
aujourd'hui c'est que je suis quasiment
sûr de faire 5 % donc je suis rembourser
je fonctionne comme ça uniquement sur
des prêts bancaires
merci je vais bédié d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir dans l'indie politique
demain à la même heure de 18h15 à 19h le
débat du mardi s'intéressera au logement
social
et puis demain matin c'est le docteur
denis lamblin qui viendra parler du
syndrome d'alcoolisation foetale avec
phil dent ni à partir de 7h dans la
matinale dans quelques instants ciel
audi qui vous accompagnent après les
infos bonne soirée
[Musique]
/
non
m
né
[Musique]
t
elle
[Musique]
com
quand et sous lui
[Musique]
et quand
il ya des sujets qui font débat le
chantier de la route du littoral opinion
qui divergent je ne suis pas d'accord
analyse qui diffère chacun de prendre
ses responsabilités et pour se faire sa
propre opinion
c'est